Hello and welcome to this special
edition of under the skin with me
Russell brand.
I'll be talking to doctor professor Dr
Jordan Peterson.
I've spoken to him before,
but this special commemorative was not
really a commemorative chat.
It's not a tea towel for the royal
wedding between Meghan Markle and Prince
Harry.
It's a to celebrate the release on paper
back of my book recovery.
And look at it now on Amazon.
It's six pound 50,
I think might be six pound,
47.
We talk about that book recovery.
We talked about the principles of
recovery is a road to enlightenment.
We talk about Dr Peterson's book.
12 rules for life is an interesting
chat.
Talking about myth.
We do of course go through some of the
main stays of Professor Peterson's,
uh,
a water cannon of ideas that you
commonly talked about.
But also I think we really get to the
heart of it and discover some.
Uh,
some people think there is an exclusion
of warmth that I think sometimes when
talking about and his ideas and he's
insistent on individual culpability and
responsibility,
we get into that stuff quite deeply.
I think it's a great chat.
Those you don't know who Jordan Peterson
is yet.
We're.
Have you been obviously not watching him
at the Hammersmith Apollo with 5,000
others,
so yeah,
we're talking to Jordan Peterson.
I'm amber skin.
Thanks for joining me and do check out
my book recovery on paperback.
Thank you
Dr Jordan Peterson.
Thank you for coming on under the skin.
It's lovely to see you again.
It's good to see you too.
It's nice to meet in London.
It's different,
isn't it?
We're both of us were exiled in Los
Angeles in our last conversation,
but I enjoyed it very much.
I've got a lot from it.
I'm happy to talk to you on.
This is very much home turf for me.
Now.
We're in London.
We're in a publishing office.
You've been promoting your book
opportunity.
That's why you're here.
A couple of public lectures.
How do you find that now?
How do you finding what I thought in a
way I've been comparing you to the
British opposition leader,
Jeremy Corbyn in that you've been doing
this for ages and now you're
experiencing a,
uh,
an almost perhaps unprecedented level of
attention,
but I'm assuming that your skill set is
applicable.
You're a lecturer,
you're a clinical psycho analyst,
so it's not like,
oh my God,
there's cameras.
Right,
right.
Well,
I mean the,
the,
the large scale lectures aren't doing,
aren't that much different in kind from
the lectures I was doing at the
university.
I mean the venues are larger and.
Yeah.
But the Hammersmith Apollo 3000 seats,
I think maybe there were.
Yeah,
there were 5,000
at the Apollo.
Well,
that's where you're not nervous.
I'm not as nervous doing that as I am
often going to talk to journalists,
individual journalists because like the
thing about those venues,
there's a variety of things about them
that work in my favor.
I mean,
I like talking to crowds,
you know,
I've always enjoyed lecturing and so
lecturing to several thousand people
isn't much different than lecturing to
several hundred people.
But I also know that the people who've
come are there happy to be there,
like I'm,
I'm,
I'm speaking to a welcoming crowd and
so,
and it's all,
all of the details are essentially under
my control.
So.
So it's not,
it,
I'm actually enjoying it quite a bit.
I mean I'm apprehensive beforehand
because,
well,
because you should be,
you know,
I want to do a good job and I want to
make sure things go well and I want to
get through the material properly and,
and,
and get a little farther in my thinking
than I have been in and I'm trying to
make each time I lecture better than the
last time and I don't obviously,
I always don't succeed at that.
But.
But it's good.
I'm enjoying it.
And my wife is very good travel
companion.
She's very stable and she helps me plan
my days and so we've got it down to a
bit of a routine.
I would say Tammy is in the room with
us.
We have already met previously in Los
Angeles.
You wouldn't be on my,
there isn't my,
it's just in case listeners are
wondering why perhaps they might be able
to detect my voice.
I'm occasionally glancing towards the
spouse.
The reason is because I am now.
Well,
I'm curious,
when you're doing these lectures,
is there not a performance component?
Do you not feel?
Definitely,
yeah.
Well sure.
I mean a lecture theater is a theater.
You and,
and lecture is a form of theater now.
It's a serious form of theater,
but theater can be serious.
No one and there's a seat because partly
what I'm doing is I'm presenting ideas
to an audience,
but I'm also modeling the act of
engaging with ideas and that's the
theatrical at end of it and I don't give
the same talk twice.
Like I have my stories and I have my
collection of things I know and I talk
about,
but I try to.
I try to do two things.
I try to.
I'm always talking to specific
individuals in the audience and so I'm
having a conversation with the audience
and so that's,
that's part of the dynamic element of
the performance.
And the other thing I'm trying to do is
to further my thinking on the topics
that I'm addressing and there is a
theatrical element to that because it's,
it's like,
I think the closest thing really that it
compares to is probably stand up comedy,
although I think the routines that
comedians have are probably more well
and formally practiced than the ones
that,
you know,
than,
than the,
than the talks that I,
that I engage in.
I don't really think of it as delivering
a lecture to an audience.
I'm trying to think about complicated
things in real time with an audience
there to participate and to use the
audience as an indicator of whether what
I'm saying is gripping and
comprehensible you apprehension and,
and,
uh,
understandable Adrenalin prior to going
on stage doesn't lead you to lean into
stick in it,
which would be the opposite of what
you're describing.
One,
to remain
engaged in a kind of dialectic process
of discovery.
Because I thought,
I mean obviously I am a comedian.
So like for,
for us,
I would argue there is a,
there is a distinction between
performing for before 200 people or
5,000
people around 200.
I feel like I'm very relaxed,
I'm comfortable.
I feel like I've got a lot of space in
there.
A $5,000
like sharpen up.
Now you've got no room particularly
because the other crucial difference is
there needs to be a laugh every 20,
30 seconds.
If there isn't,
it gets pretty frosty up.
There is,
it is appealing to me as a comedian
that's interested in interested in
furthering intellectual debate,
looking at the new intersections between
politics and spirituality.
Perhaps they've always been there.
These are some,
these evaporating context.
The emergence of new ideas perhaps
perhaps best exemplified by your own
particular trajectory is interesting to
me that that these spaces are now
becoming available for forms of types of
performance that aren't so contingent.
It is on rapture and planner.
Right?
I know it is a very strange thing and
I'm not sure what to make of it.
You know,
you see Sam Harris doing something quite
similar.
Richard Dawkins is doing something quite
similar and,
and it's,
it's,
I mean I was thinking because I've been
trying to conceptualize this and,
and one one comparable audience or one
comparable situation is probably that
of,
of standup comedians.
Another I suspect are traveling
evangelists eventually it evangelical
type.
Yeah.
No,
because there.
But of course what they're doing is
explicitly religious.
This is this,
this has elements of both of those.
And what's emerging that's so
interesting is that there's a clear
public appetite for high level
intellectual conversation.
If it's,
if it's dynamic and I don't know what,
what's accounting for that,
all of a sudden maybe it's because these
sorts of discussions aren't taking place
like they should in the classical media
space.
You might be right there.
Jordan,
I mean to slightly mangle to slightly
mangled the young quote that you use in
your book.
I'm 12 rules.
I'm really enjoying actually,
uh,
like the one could infer motivation from
results perhaps is that the political
discourse,
social discourse has become superficial
and detached from meaning from purpose,
from experience.
That there is an opening appetite for
substance that people are starting to.
What you know,
and,
and as you said about theater before,
you know,
the origins of theater and the origins
of religion are closely connected and
both of them still our debt or at least
functionally must relate to meaning
purpose,
giving us stories that help illuminate
the path.
I think that.
I think that's,
that's,
that's there's something about that
that's profoundly correct.
I think that know that the New York
Times has recently written about the
rise of the so called intellectual dark
web,
which is a term that Eric Weinstein so
brilliantly coined,
I would say.
And,
and very thoughtfully.
Um,
I think that the thing that unites the
people who are loosely grouped into that
collection is that they are having
serious conversations with an audience
that they respect and they're very
diverse range of people.
They don't certainly don't like salmon.
Sam Harris and I disagree about many
things for example,
and uh,
but Sam respects his audiences and he's,
and he's engaging them in extremely
serious discourse about very deep topics
now about the structure of reality
actually and,
and the relationship between science and
religion and,
and,
and the.
And I think it is a consequence of the
fact that not only has our public
discourse,
let's say in the media and in politics
become shallow.
I think it's become unbearably shallow
in the universities.
So yeah,
well,
because it's become so ideological,
you know,
and it's just not helpful.
Look,
I was interviewed by a New York Times
journalist last week.
A Nelly was her name and she's going to
publish this on Sunday and she did a
literature degree at Columbia and she
told me that she was quite appalled
actually by her degree,
uh,
especially in,
in,
in hindsight,
she told me that she didn't know until
she graduated,
that there was any other way of reading
great literature than through a
postmodern lense.
And the postmodern lens takes a book and
basically you take a book,
whatever it happens to be,
and you decide which power hierarchy the
author was serving and who is he,
who he or she has excluded from
consideration.
So it's completely read through a
political lens as if the book is nothing
but a tool of political and economic
domination essentially.
And that's the assumption.
And like,
look,
everything's contaminated by politics
and power to some degree,
right?
But that doesn't mean that there's
nothing to art and literature except in
service of,
of like group domination.
It's an appalling way of looking at the
world.
It would be an extraordinary bias to
bring to Jane.
Eyre is difficult to sort of make sense
of it through that Lens.
Then of course in economics and
politics,
like,
yeah,
of course important themes are going to
be present in great works of art,
but uh,
I,
I'm interest.
They're still great works of art.
That's the thing.
And it's like,
well,
even even with something as transient as
comedy,
let's say mean you can't reduce comedy
to the political or the economic and,
and,
and comics who become too ideological,
let's say,
like musicians who become too
ideological.
They're just not funny anymore.
You have to be,
I mean,
you can have your viewpoint left or
right,
that's fine and people do,
but you have to be able to transcend
that viewpoint continually and you have
to be able to criticize it because
otherwise you're not a music.
You just become a demagogue of sorts.
Yes.
I would agree that once there's a rubric
to which you
come in slave,
that becomes a dogmatic then,
then there's no room for nuance.
There's no room for hypocrisy.
Humor,
the transcendent Mirth,
chaos.
These forces need to be unleashed.
There's also things you can no longer
laugh about because you're,
you know,
you're so committed to your axioms.
You can't,
you,
you dare not transgress against them.
And if that's deadly,
if you're a comedian,
because the rule for comedy would be,
and this is something I like about,
about Sarah Silverman for example,
is she will say anything if she thinks
it's funny.
She's very daring in that manner and
like I've heard her tell jokes that,
you know,
really would curl your hair,
but you can tell by watching or
something will pop into her head and
part of her golf,
tennis,
I don't know if I should say this and
then she'll say it and it's often like
horribly funny and horribly funny.
Is a good kind of funny.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's daring and,
and it's something I really admire about
comedians too,
is that they'll,
they'll take that risk and,
and it's something also that I've found
disturbing about with regards to the
many things I find disturbing about
university campuses is that so many
comedians won't go perform on university
campuses anymore because they can't be
funny.
People get offended and it's a false.
So fan of offended.
I think you're right.
I mean I think it's like a kind of Simon
says type of a like,
do you know that game?
Do you have that game in your language?
Just like are there certain things that
we know we're not allowed to say.
There's certain things that we know
we're supposed to think.
There's a kind of a,
a kind of form you like Donald's a
courtly behavior,
I've heard it referred to as that we are
meant to pay homage to a particular type
of set of protocols and manners and it's
not necessarily anchored to a real.
Morality is not anchored to a sort of a
sense of spirit to a sense of love or
kindness is about like,
these are the rules that we abide by.
I want to talk to you a bit about,
uh,
the 12 steps and the model for handling
addiction that I've written about myself
in my book recovery because I want to
see what you think of it like so like
the 12 steps have anonymous fellowships,
which I,
if I were to belong to them,
I wouldn't be able to say I belong to
them without breaching their code of
anonymity.
But uh,
the,
what's positive about this approach to
addiction is a,
as we have discussed off Mike,
a vet,
it creates community like the other
people that I've got a similar endeavor.
And in fact it was young,
the identified this,
this solution.
He said that like,
people that have got chronic addiction
addiction issues will struggle to change
unless they have a spiritual realization
of some kind on the support for
community.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm the spiritual realization component
that's supported by
the relevant addiction literature.
One of the classic cures for addiction
is spiritual transformation and the
hardcore scientists have laid that out
as as a reality in the addiction
literature degree because the ease more
secular language around that as
spiritual transformation could just be a
change of perspective or a renewal,
a radical change of perspective from an
a and it typically in my experience,
that's from a self centered view of self
obsessive view about gain,
your own needs met a solid cystic
narcissistic perspective of low life is
this is just an adventure where I go
around trying to accumulate and accrue
to,
Oh wow,
I'm here to be of service.
That's of the transition in right
microscopically,
but in addition to a community like
having connections between one another,
the 12 steps themselves I think are an
interesting model for transformation and
shouldn't be overlooked and in fact,
what my book was about is could that
method be transposed to anybody who's
interested in change?
So I wanted to talk to you about that to
get your perspective on them.
The first step is acknowledging that you
were powerless over our addiction in
your life has become unmanageable.
Just admitted this,
I don't want to be in this situation.
Okay,
so there's two parts to that admission.
A one is that you're in trouble.
Yeah,
and I guess there's three.
You're in trouble and it's serious.
Things could be better and you don't
have the wherewithal at the moment to
make them better.
So the thing that's interesting about
that is there's a kind of radical
humiliation and humility that goes along
with that because you say,
I have a problem and what I know at the
moment isn't sufficient to solve it.
Great.
Because now you've opened yourself up to
the possibility of learning something as
you say,
well,
I don't know.
I don't know enough to fix this.
It's like,
okay,
well you could learn.
And one of the things that's so
interesting about people is that if they
decide they have a problem and they also
noticed that they could learn,
the probability that they will learn
goes way up.
That's very interesting.
You've actually conflated the first
three steps there in your analysis of
the first one because the first one is
admission that there's a problem.
The second one is recognizing that
things could improve like counter
believe that power greater than
ourselves could restore us to sanity and
the third one is made a decision to turn
our life and our will over to the care
of God as we understood God.
So like,
you know,
yeah.
We could talk about that from a secular
goes back.
Well,
we could talk about that from a secular
perspective and say,
well,
there's a.
there's a higher order moral principle
that needs to be brought into the
situation and you sort of described that
right at the beginning of the question
because you said,
well,
what?
Partly what you do when you move from an
addicted state,
from a psychological perspective is
moved from a viewpoint of the
gratification of immediate desire and
and maybe the accumulation of things as
a marker of success to the notion that
no,
you actually have a higher purpose and
that higher purpose might involve being
of service.
That could be of service to yourself,
which means you wouldn't be addicted
anymore.
Because that's not a good way of being,
of service to yourself.
But I've serviced to yourself and the
broader community,
however you might define that that's a
higher order purpose and can integrate
your motivations at at a level that
doesn't leave you at the whim of
impulse.
That's the purpose of a higher order
motivation.
So okay,
so we've got three.
He asked that.
That's the first phase to get you to
that position where you're willing to
change,
believe in the possibility of change and
accept help in order to achieve that
change.
The fourth and fifth steps are about
inventorying.
Get like this is where the 12 step
program becomes a fusion of spirituality
and psychoanalysis because the fourth
step is like a a four column method
where you write down a list of all your
resentments in your life and childhood
resentments,
have resentments against the government,
people you work with,
you write it all down,
and then there's a diagnostic tool where
you identify what it is in you that
doesn't like that.
And and also interestingly in a in 12
step theology that's called it,
it says that anything,
anytime that you are personally
disturbed there is you have to take
responsibility for it.
To a degree,
there is something in you that's been
effective.
It should at least ask yourself that
question.
Is it me or is it the world?
Yes.
Well,
let's consider first the possibility
that it might be.
I wrote about that in the sixth rule,
right?
Put Your assault how?
Say around the house.
Yes,
yes.
In fact,
I've got our two Ra,
like my idea to truncate it and somewhat
more as a linguistically explicit
explosive Laden version of the 12 steps.
And I've got your 12 rules for life here
and they don't necessarily correlate,
but like,
because like you say your first one,
stand up straight with your shoulders
back.
I that.
So a great chapter I think I love about,
you know,
the lobster staff and they sort of the
uh,
the ancient,
timeless,
all,
most roots of hierarchies and the
chemicals that are at play.
What's happening when you're,
what,
what is that play?
When we talk about self esteem,
I'm like,
and this year,
the sixth one set your own house in
perfect order.
I said before you criticize the world
steps four and five in the,
in a 12 step program,
deal with that inventory.
What's going on in your life inventory,
what your baggage is in your own
personal opinion.
I think it's very practical that it's
like,
well,
let's say you want to fix up your house,
which is actually quite a lot like
fixing yourself up,
which is a very common dream metaphor.
Well,
the first thing you want to do is go
look around and see what needs to be
fixed.
You know,
and,
and the,
the interesting thing about that,
this is akin to what comedians do,
is that as soon as you're willing to
admit Comedians,
look at a problem and then rise above it
right away and make a joke about it.
But as soon as you're willing to admit
that you have a problem,
then you're immediately contacted the
part of yourself that's at least strong
enough to admit that you have a problem.
And so as soon as the act of admitting
the problem is actually the first step
to solving it.
So you might say,
well,
and it it's an optimistic step because
you might say,
oh my God,
I can't admit to that I have a problem
because what if I can't solve it or.
Exactly.
So then maybe you won't admit to it.
If you do to it,
you're simultaneously admitting to the
possibility that you could solve it and
then it can actually become something
that's optimistic.
You can say,
well,
my life is horrible.
It's like,
okay,
but I'm doing 50 things wrong.
Well Great.
I can fix those things and then maybe it
wouldn't be so horrible.
It demonstrated the admission itself
demonstrates progression and possibility
for further progression.
I think it relates.
That's why humility is always stressed
in,
in great religious traditions.
Humility is precisely that.
It's like you have to look at why you're
not so good.
Yeah,
and and you know that that has to break
down your pride to some degree in your
arrogance.
It's like,
well that's great because if you break
down your pride and your arrogance,
then you're primed to learn and you can
solve your problems.
So there's nothing in that.
It's a bit crushing to begin with
because you might think,
oh my God,
there's really a lot of things wrong
with me,
but at least then you're on the on the
road to fixing them.
My personal journey of recovery has been
like a kind of death,
a light,
you know,
like when I was 27 it was like the death
of the drug addict self.
That guy does funny because I told Tammy
when we were coming here today that when
you were 27,
you made the decision to live.
I knew it was 27 because that's when
people,
I'm going to say like you,
but you know,
celebrities who,
who are sort of on fire,
they die all the time at 27 because they
don't make that decision.
They decided that they don't decide that
they're going to take that final step
into maturation.
They want to hold onto that Peter Pan
thing,
that,
that pause.
You bet you exactly that.
They want to hold onto that and you
can't hold onto that and live yes,
and then there's a further death.
I'm noticing now in my early forties so
that are now at the midway point have
been made in that sort of Dante,
esquire and now I'm moving towards the
grave and now I'm like,
there's a different kind of alertness
and merging and back to this step,
four and five minutes in this process of
inventorying.
After you've might an imagery and
you've,
you've correctly,
you've honestly and openly put down
everything,
incidents of child abuse,
things that you've said to other people,
things that your shame.
Once you've been willing to inscribe
your shame,
then you tell another person,
a person that you trust.
In the original literature it says,
you know,
it could be a cleric,
a doctor,
or wherever.
It typically in a 12 step structures.
It's like a mentor figure,
but that has the.
That's the role of confession,
which obviously a huge part of
psychoanalysis.
The point in your book,
I think this pertains to is when you
took like the Dragon and the dragon gave
that.
You said there was that Kid's book that
you read where it talks about the dragon
getting bigger and bigger.
If it's not identified.
I think four and five are somewhat like
that.
Yeah.
Well,
in part of the point of that kid's book
is that as soon as you turn around and
look at something,
it tends to shrink and that's partly
because imagine that you have a memory
that you won't confront.
Well,
there's something in that memory that's
terrifying,
but and that means it's sort of
associated with everything else that's
terrifying and so it's horror.
It's horrible,
but then when you turn around and look
at it,
you think,
yeah,
it's horrible,
but it's horrible in this precise and
defined way,
and that takes it away from all the
other potential horrors of it.
It starts to shrink it right away and
also makes you into the thing that can
turn around and look at the horror,
which is a real,
real positive transformation lacked on
your part.
So it's true that somehow in the being,
being prescriptive and being specific,
the problem becomes manageable because
it's limitless,
not fuel.
It becomes a apocalyptic in the end.
What?
What's the worst thing that Kevin is?
I could be destroyed and everyone I love
could be destroyed itself,
could be destroyed.
And until you say,
well actually know what this is is you
feel inadequate because you weren't role
multiple.
Correct.
All right,
well I can maybe take care of that.
Right?
There's still bad,
but it's not everything.
And then you,
you phrased that exactly right.
Is that without that attentive
delimiting it becomes apocalyptic.
That.
And that's a very,
very old idea.
So one of the things that happens in the
Mesopotamian creation myth,
Enuma elish,
is that the gods are created.
They're,
they're the,
they're the offspring of chaos.
That's a good way of thinking about it
and they become very careless and they
destroy their category system.
They destroy their father essentially
and chaos comes flooding back.
And that's what happens to people who
aren't looking at things and delimiting
them properly.
They become up apocalyptic and do the
mint.
So,
but sometimes in a mythology there is
the positive too,
confronting confronting of the God age
promethium.
So sometimes we need to steal,
steal the fire.
Sometimes we need to challenge these
orthodoxies,
don't we?
Yes sir.
Absolutely.
I mean,
part part of the well,
part of the death that you're describing
is actually the confrontation with a
form of tyrant,
like your previously addicted self was
the tyrant over your emergent self.
Yes,
and so it's an internal tyrant and you
said it was predicated on a false value
system.
That's a false set of gods essentially,
and so you had to confront that.
That is a kind of death.
I also think that some the addiction or
addictive tendencies,
and I don't mean as severe as chemical
dependency or forms of addiction
addiction or a kind of self constructed
formaldehyde to preserve you in the
state of trauma,
but trauma is acknowledged.
No means to navigate trauma are present
because of the isolation,
because you have no mentor,
you have no.
You have no doctrine,
you have no community,
so addiction steps in,
this is how our preserved,
this is how I will not die.
I will find this notice that is a habit,
a repeated pattern to sustain you,
a holding pattern so that you don't die
because there is no way out.
There's no guide,
there's no path.
You're just in the forest and there
isn't a way out,
so I thought that addiction for a
personal experience in that I hope and
suspect more broadly is a means for sort
of status for preservation after trauma.
The rupture occurs is not addressed and
a means for survival emerges in the form
of addiction.
Addiction is not your nemesis is your
friend,
at least while you're in,
whilst you're in.
There's certainly a literature on
addiction that indicates that many
people use addictive substances as a
form of self medication and they tend to
find the drug that best,
best medicates them,
let's say.
And for different people.
That's different.
Drugs.
Alcohol,
yeah.
Now say one of the other things that I'm
proposing in my book is to use one of
the grandiose terminology is that the,
uh,
they template for a recovery from
obvious forms of addiction could be
applicable to less evident forms of
addiction,
just patterns and habits.
And because so far the things that
you've laid out would be,
would be in keeping with that idea.
Well,
you admit to the problem.
I really also,
I think the idea of laying out your
resentments is unbelievably useful
because that's also a way of dealing
with the malevolence within you that
might interfere with your own recovery
because you're angry at yourself.
If you're angry at your parents,
if you're angry at the world,
the probability that you're going to be
in the mental state that's going to
allow you to chart a positive course for
yourself is very,
very low.
How can you have a clear and authentic
relationship with your wife if you've
not correctly understood what you feel
about your own mother?
If you feel like that you are enmeshed
or trapped in some way?
How am I supposed to have or have not
understood that if I've not gained a new
perspective,
if I've not transcended it by sharing is
another person that in in the sleeping
beauty story and the Disney story,
when the prince is encapsulated in the
castle,
in the dungeon at the end and before he
goes and rescues sleeping,
beauty,
he has to confront his terrible mother.
She turns into the dragon of chaos
itself.
He has to use honesty and truth to
confront her,
and until he does that,
he can't free the maiden from her sleep.
Yeah,
so that's called the,
that's called the freeing of the anima
from the negative mother archetype and
union psychology.
It's precisely that and that,
and that negative feminine will be
overlaid on your partner unless you,
unless you're able to clarify it and
clarify your relationship with it.
And that could be something like
overprotection or it could,
you know,
in your past or it could be neglect for
that matter,
or it could be the rejection at many at
the hands of many,
many women before you encountered this
woman that you were going to bring that
bitterness forward as a kind of
projection.
If we are unwilling to undertake this
kind of excavation,
then we asked them to continually have
relationships that are cutaneous.
Just a superficial coordinates will
govern our experience in relationships.
Uh,
so that's the repetition compulsion from
a Freudian perspective is that,
that isn't how Freud explained it.
That's how I would explain it.
But,
but the simple explanation of it is,
well,
if you bring the same set of priests
unexamined presuppositions to every
situation,
the same fate will play out.
You might say,
well,
those women are the same.
It's like,
well actually no,
but the part of the part of them that
you're able to make contact with acts
the same every time.
That's a very different thing.
Brilliant.
And this is where six and seven,
the next steps are chronologically
occur,
but
there's six.
Having done this inventory,
you recognize what patterns have been at
play in your life,
which particular in the lexicon of the
recovery defects of character,
of governed you often pride wanting to
control other people's perspective,
self pity,
self centeredness,
intolerance,
inpatients,
green jealousy,
envy,
lost slope for you.
Identify the seven deadly sins and how
they play out in your life essentially.
Yes.
And so,
and you become in step six is about
becoming willing to live differently.
The saying,
are you actually willing to let go of
last?
Are you or do you like lost when it
comes to it,
do you like being impatient?
Does it serve you in some way?
To be slothful,
it's.
It's highly probable that it does.
Yeah.
No,
it's.
It's,
it's easy.
It's gratifying.
It's powerful,
it's pleasurable,
especially in the short term like
there's lots of.
There are reasons that people are
tempted by by the seven deadly sins.
Gloria,
and that's exactly right.
There's a dark romantic and you really
see that in the depths of celebrities
around 27 is they.
They fall in love with the allure of
that kind of have that romantic death
and he does the men,
so the Anti Libido,
that dark libido,
that death force,
so with the.
Once you have diagnosed,
which particular defects of character
have been most prominent in your path
and become willing to let go of them.
This step seven is making a concerted
and real effort to live without them and
this is where it kind of comes down to
sacrifice theory.
That's what are you willing to sacrifice
in order to move forward,
you have to give up something that you
love and you may have to give up the
thing you love the best.
That's the fundamental sacrificial
motif.
Sacrifices and the unattractive idea in
our self.
In in our society that's based on
consuming and indulgence and this is not
something that I would like.
So this is again,
perhaps you were you a nice I'm.
What differ is that I would not,
whilst this will not change about the
individual's engagement or kind of step
one and acknowledgement that needs to be
changed.
This is where I say there is a social
responsibility,
but for whatever reason our society has
become a manifestation of these darker
impulses.
These are the prevalent forces,
at least in the kind of society I live
in.
I think it was like to live in China or
Libya.
I'm just saying like in London,
like what?
Your emphasis on immediate
gratification,
too much emphasis on.
Because immediate gratification is a
tool of consumerism.
This would be my argument.
So like I it,
but at this point in the program,
it's where the spirituality becomes,
I find personally undeniable.
But you have to,
uh,
you have to call to something else.
You have to in a sense,
be lay yourself open.
The idea of prayer becomes quite
important now.
So there's a,
there's a union idea there.
So the union self is the thing that
guides the ego through transformations.
So imagine the ego,
which is what you think you are,
or the thing about the ego is the ego
can be wrong
and the ego can die and be reborn.
So what that indicates is that there's
something underneath the Eagle can guide
that process of transformation and
partly what you're calling on when you
call on this higher power is at least
from a psychological perspective,
it's a decision to rely on that thing
that can guide you through
transformation.
Yes,
because surely as we said in relation to
another,
we are likely relate into a set of
coordinates that we impose on info
commerce.
The female.
The same would be true of the cell that
we have created an impression,
an egoic impression we've constructed
and our official self.
But beneath it there is our higher self
or an exterior self that comes often
composed of.
It's often composed of things that you
refuse to or we're willing to develop.
And so when young talks about,
for example,
the incorporation of the shadow is that
you've constructed a Nigo and there's
things it can do and can't do,
that it's allowed to do and it isn't
allowed to do,
and then there's a shadow domain that
would consist of those things that you
could do but haven't.
And some of that's terrible,
but some of it's what you need to break
free.
Is there a,
a infinite variety in the shadow or are
there sort of templates there?
Would you say that you know,
a common component of the last
aggression aggression because they're
the most.
The mobilized,
yeah.
They're the two that are most difficult
to integrate into the ego because
aggression destroys and of course lost
subsumes.
The individual to,
to,
to well to sexual sexual desire is such
a lust,
isn't identified as a very powerful
self.
It can,
it can subsume.
So I suppose that's why a lot of
theological doctrines focus on the
control of last another.
There is,
of course,
it's a disruptive force,
you know,
because for example,
if you make a medium to longterm
relationship with someone in new
negotiate that that provides you with a
stable structure that can operate across
your entire life is good for you.
It's good for them,
it's good for your kids,
it's good for society,
but then if you're really attracted to
someone momentarily,
you can be driven to act on that and and
every,
all the rest of that can burn up.
It's not good,
and so it's no wonder that it's viewed
as a force of tremendous disruption.
Now it's also a force of tremendous
life,
right?
Because you want to be attracted to
people.
You want to have that,
that,
that vital libido as part of part of
what's driving you forward,
but hopefully it's on your side and not
working against you.
And so you know,
if you're successful and you've put
yourself together and you're
disciplined,
you should still be maximally sexually
attractive,
but it should be under your control.
You're not a,
you're not the puppet of that force
anymore.
It's integrated into you and that's a
much better way to manage it.
How do you,
in your understanding,
how is the shadow incorporated?
What rituals,
what ceremonies,
what behaviors successfully incorporate
the shadow?
Say in using the example of last week,
what's a way back in for the sort of the
that it's been disembodied or repressed
or it's a safe way for it back?
Is there one?
Well,
I think part of it is to,
is to admit to your desires within your
own relationship,
you know,
because you might say,
well,
I'm,
I'm tired of my wife.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
maybe,
maybe you're tired of the games that
you're intelligent enough to play with
your wife,
but she's as plurry potential as you
are,
and so you have to admit to your
desires,
let's say,
and maybe you have to make them
consciously manifest within your own
relationship and then you know,
when people can do that,
people do that by,
by dressing up or by,
by playing sexually,
I would say.
Yeah,
play.
Exactly.
That plays a transformative element and
that's it.
You know,
and it might be that you're
uncomfortable with the idea of,
of your wife as sexual play thing
because you think that a woman who's
married should be proper and Prim and
should only behave sexually in a certain
way,
in which case,
well,
that becomes stale and dull and you're
more likely to be tempted by something
on the outside.
For me,
that's a very obvious example of how
habitualized thinking is prohibitive
even without reaching the extremes of
self destructive,
addictive tendencies.
If I have a habit of regarding my wife
as,
as object day,
even if that's not a objectification,
is we're typically take care by limiting
beliefs about my wife,
that the tools that breakdown addictive,
uh,
thought patterns could be used to create
new terrains,
new liberty,
new play.
Thank you.
Um,
so like,
so once you've done up to step seven,
which is essentially a step seven,
you're right,
it's a sacrifice of the old self and
handing over to the,
some kind of sublime divine self.
Um,
the,
the step eight is you make a list of
people that you have harmed and become
willing to make amends to them as you
look back at your part and go,
God,
I shouldn't have stolen that.
I shouldn't have done that.
I treated that person badly.
That was wrong.
I lied.
So it's moral,
it becomes quite real repentance,
right?
And Atonement,
atonement is at one meant.
And if you're carrying transgressions
that you regard as transcriptions now
and your life,
then you don't want to carry those for
you want to,
you want to step forward in life without
that moral burden because you will have
contempt for yourself otherwise,
and you won't take care of yourself.
It also,
in a sense what you're talking about,
about allowing lust backend incorporate
in last.
Then,
uh,
this is a more,
a broader method for incorporating
annexed aspects of the self.
Like,
you know,
how can you fully love?
How can I fully love myself?
I know I treated that person abominably
well,
if I go back and say that was wrong,
I did you wrong.
I owe you an amends.
You,
you invite that part of your life in you
amended your path through life as well
as teaching yourself that,
that is not the way we proceed anymore.
That step pay,
and then that's a real.
That's,
that's taking our real action in the
world.
It's not a hypothetical at that point,
right?
It's kind of like telling people what
you've written down about your,
uh,
about your faults.
Yes.
Because it makes it real.
When you,
when you're acting it out with someone
else,
it's not only a mental thing at that
point.
Furthermore indicates step by step a is
done separate from the step eight is
right up the list of people.
Step nine is now.
Go through it.
It makes the distinction,
I think,
to create a space for you where you're
going,
where you're not continually thinking,
I'm not fucking doing that.
I'm not going to apologize.
I was abused by them.
Fuck that.
They did as much wrong as I did not.
The point is not the point and also I
think they might've done more wrong than
you did,
yes,
but you're still stuck with the fact
that you did something wrong.
That's wrong,
that's not good,
and if you refuse to surmount the
obstacle of like inner,
some arbitrary measure of who is more
wrong,
then you continue to cast yourself in
victim hood.
That's you have no personal autonomy,
so I choose to go for it.
It doesn't matter if you're only five
percent at fault and it also doesn't
matter if the other person apologizes to
you,
they should.
It would be better for them.
It might make things lay out.
That's not the point and this perhaps is
where what I think is significant that
now your life has become not negotiation
between you and other be beings as they
materially present themselves,
but between yourself and this higher
purpose that has been declared earlier,
that you are now operating on the common
spiritual plane.
You are no longer about.
If I do that,
I'll get that.
It precisely doesn't matter if a person
goes,
I don't care if you apologize or not.
Religious language that would be
expressed as the discovery of your
father in heaven instead of your earthly
father because your father in heaven
would be the higher spiritual authority
to which you owe allegiance and and you
can think about that either in religious
terms or a nonreligious terms,
is that what you've done is you've been
in some sense as you've abstracted the,
the idea of a higher authority and a
higher purpose and you've decided to
devote yourself to that.
That's a religious app and that's
precisely antithetical to postmodernism
is saying that,
no,
no.
There is an essence.
There is a country,
there is a way.
There is a trust.
That's right.
That's,
that's,
that's what is precisely antithetical.
Yes,
because the postmodern claim is that
there are multiple ways of looking at
the world many ways,
and that's true,
but the antithesis of that is yes.
Just because there's multiple ways of
looking at the world doesn't mean there
are multiple proper ways of looking at
the wounds.
In fact,
there's a very narrow range of proper
ways of looking at the world.
My,
my concern with atheism has always been
it's sort of easy affiliation with
nihilism or why don't we just wondering
is fucking people.
Then that sort of like,
that's like that's where my mind
immediately goes,
if there is not an order,
why not just smash everything to
smithereens and you're saying
ideologically that is what's happening
ideologically with deconstructing God.
We're the deconstructing morality with
an agenda.
We're deconstructing and that was the
danger that both both nature and dusty
Esq pointed to clearly.
It's like you dispense with the
transcendent principle and you open up
the landscape for impulsive nihilism.
What are they responding to?
Post enlightenment rationalism.
Is that what does the ski in nature or
responding to why they weren't
responding essentially to the idea of
the death of God,
both of them and that
explicitly and is an enlightenment idea.
Like where is there,
where is death of God happening at?
The hair should be at the hands of a,
of a kind of arrogant and narrow
rationalism and the materialism.
Yeah,
and the exposition of the exponentially.
That has led us to where we're going
now,
which is that kind of okay.
Sort of digging the earth from beneath
our feet,
putting us to the base.
That's,
that's a.
that's the hypothesis.
Precisely.
10,
11.
The last three steps.
Step 10 is a like a continued to make
inventory,
so like let this process continued for
me in psycho analytic terms.
I'll see a therapist obviously like a
lot is when like when there's a moment I
know any spike in my energy if I go,
oh,
I felt so.
That was interesting.
I felt jealous there or I felt I felt
small in that moment.
These are the moments I know and go,
oh,
how was I participate in that?
What belief of mine was being
challenged?
Is that a helpful belief?
Belief being a thought that I like
having a at 11,
that's a kind of consciousness is like,
well,
I'm going to fall apart.
I'm going to make mistakes.
I don't want to make mistakes.
I'm going to keep an eye out for when I
do make mistakes and I'm going to make
them conscious and then I'm going to try
to work on them bringing them into into
consciousness because my fear,
my number one fear on a personal level
and possibly on a social level,
I don't know quite how to extrapolate or
conflate those two notions is
unconsciousness.
I get very afraid when I'm dealing with
unconscious individually when I'm.
People don't know why they're doing what
they're doing.
He may see this in sort of violent rage
or even in less dramatic theatrical
behaviors feel.
There's a great idea that works.
At the bottom of the Christian
mythological tradition is that a little
bit of consciousness destroyed the
original paradise.
We became conscious enough to be aware
of our own mortality,
but the cure for that is way more
consciousness,
not a return to unconsciousness.
Yes,
there's no going back.
There's no going back.
I sometimes think the plethora of Zombie
movies is they don't know they're
already dead and like so like that.
That danger of the Zombie is the danger
of the desire for unconsciousness as a,
as a solution to life's problems.
And I think that this is again something
we're being invited to participate in
for consumerism that live your life
continually on the frequency of
unconscious energy,
such a desire and fear that we're not
being.
We're not being invited to participate
on the level of consciousness,
conscious interaction,
presence in the moment.
While you could make the case if you
made the case that consumerism promotes
the gratification of immediate desires
above all else.
I think it does.
That's my,
that's what I'm pushing for.
Um,
with this original sin.
Like,
so a little bit of consciousness as a
dangerous thing.
We become with our vulnerability,
our mortality,
our nakedness and corporate real nature.
But the solution to this is to become
more conscious to we have to.
So,
uh,
how do you,
how was that?
The Bible?
Yes.
Where does that get resolved?
Normally they get kicked out of the
garden.
Part of part of what happens in in the,
in the redemptive story is if you think
about Christ as a symbolic figure,
say is symbolic of the process of
transformation that we just described is
one of the.
One of the morals of the Christian
passion is that you need to radically
accept your limitations and so part of
this keeping your sins before your eyes,
which you just described.
Here's all the ways that I fall short of
the glory of God.
Let's say,
you know I make this mistake.
I make this mistake,
I make this mistake.
That's all consciousness and it's
painful,
right?
Because you think,
well,
you become more conscious.
It's this glorious process of
enlightenment and overall it is,
but the details are exactly this.
The things you need to become
consciousness conscious of are precisely
those things that you least want to
become conscious of and that this is the
motif that you identified in the
alchemical tradition because the
chemical,
the chemical model,
so to speak,
was that which you most need to be
found.
That which you most need to find will be
found where you least want to look.
Right?
Yes.
And everyone knows that's true.
Like you tell someone that they go,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that's,
I know that's true.
So,
and that's also the greatest barrier to
enlightenment because if a night moon
was all,
you know,
tulips in sunshine,
then everyone would be enlightened,
but it's not,
it's this continual bringing before
yourself all your proclivity for,
for transgression.
And that's that and that obviously
because how are you going to solve your
problems if you're not aware of them?
He wouldn't want to be old discipline.
Did a jeweled Jordan.
Well,
it's not surprising,
but the alternative is far worse.
That's the thing.
And that is the district.
Because I was very curious.
I was very curious.
Like I said,
I talked about this with Tammy when we
were coming here.
I thought Russell decided to live when
he was 27.
I can't.
I would like to know why.
So why did you,
why did you make the decision to,
to not allow what was consuming you to
kill you?
In a sense,
it was taken out of my hands for the
first time I encountered positive or
mail or 40 figures who curiously like,
or at least that we're able to address
that in particular,
I was sent to a treatment center.
I had free mumps.
I had time to think I timed to,
uh,
I,
I passed from childhood directly into
addictive behaviors.
In fact,
those addicted babies were already
present in childhood in less toxic form
in my relationship.
In retrospect,
fruit chocolate was addictive.
My relationship with pornography as an
adolescent addictive,
I was using it to,
for medical medical purposes.
So,
so when substances became an option in
adolescence,
it was seamless.
And that meant that my emotional,
my emotional growth was arrested at that
point.
The reason I was able to stop it because
inadvertent,
I was offered help.
I got,
I was given help our people that the
management company that was working with
say your serious drug addicts,
you should go away.
Okay.
So partly that meant that they re,
they regarded
you as the sort of valuable commodity
that was worth preserving.
Yes.
There was a degree of that.
Right?
Right.
Well,
no,
but that's helpful.
I mean regardless of.
Even if it's purely an economic
interest,
there's,
there's something to that.
Yeah.
So and so then you went into treatment
and you find some people say the place
that I went,
it's run by an atheist chip summers,
but the 12 step principles,
you can't unpick it from the Oxford
Group,
first century Christian Group there and
for me is more appealing when you talk
about it in terms of though I have no
problem with the sublime and the divine.
I live for that shit.
But like,
like I was always trying to get out of
my head off my face.
Those were the things I want it a
sublime experience experience of what is
beyond the material.
That's what I want to know.
So,
but once I was in that environment and
given drugs to help where I was addicted
to opiates,
so I called subutex then and sleeping
pills because I couldn't sleep.
And during that time I suppose in a way
I didn't fully address the issue of
addiction because my.
I was really promiscuous for about a
decade,
but I that,
that behavior was transplant.
It was kind of effortlessly,
but I do remember a kind of moment of
epiphany if apifany his revelation of
previously concealed to truth when it
first occurred to me,
you,
I suppose you don't have to take drugs
every day.
I remember that thought entering and it
being sort of like,
oh yeah,
I never thought about that because that
I'd found a solution.
It worked and worked as a way of
managing pain,
prevent infoview mental investigation or
discovery of conclusions that would have
been unhelpful and that wouldn't have
been able to deal with.
I think in a lot of cases,
and I'm sure there's many,
many variables,
uh,
that,
that actually chemical dependency is a
successful technique for preventing
suicide.
There is just,
this is a holding pattern to stop me
doing something more dramatic and band.
Unless people have access to an ideology
of structure and support that will help
them through that.
There's,
it's very difficult to overcome.
And I was fortunate in that I was
granted that and then grant it this
system.
And so,
and as I've been working it,
I've come to the conclusion that it is
possibly universal,
not because I think it's derived from
universal ideas.
That's why I think young I've made that
the identified some,
like if there's a spiritual experience
and then the support of community,
that's how someone could be stopped from
drinking,
continually alcoholic drinking and then
they took this process.
They were 12 original 12 step
fellowships,
took the Oxford Group,
had a program of a sort of redemption
and restitution and you know,
and like it,
it seems initially in a,
I think in a materialistic society,
counterintuitive to think that the
solution to addiction is going to be
spirit,
spiritual awakening.
But that's what it is.
And the,
the final steps are stay connected once
you like your continual inventorying for
the moment.
We think,
oh,
I felt something there that you want to
be in the moment connected.
Like I have to notice if I,
if someone makes me feel inferior or if
someone,
if I'm sexually attracted to someone,
those are the most obvious examples of
something that will take me out of my
connection.
And then the final step is,
uh,
made a hell puffers and remain awake for
it.
The Hero's journey is,
once you go into the darkness and find
something of value,
the next thing to do is to distribute
into distributed within the community to
bring it back and distributed within the
community.
Now Jordan d,
is it like it would be difficult for me
to accept that you've not been a sort of
personally affected and are not
personally angry rather than just,
um,
objectively because your personal
trajectory I suppose in the public eye
at least began with the situation in
Canada with a sort of forced speech or
however it is termed now.
So like that.
Are you able to distinguish between your
sort of sense of personal irritation?
Because I think for most people telling
me what were,
whether or not you think that he's right
there.
Academia seems like I'm an and celery
area.
It doesn't seem mainstream to most
people like,
but to you it seems as though so very
vital,
but you are an academic.
Well,
okay.
So there's,
there's two things there.
I mean,
people regard academia as ancillary,
but it's not.
The reason it's not is because the
universities train the people who run
things and so whatever's mainstream in
the universities right now,
even though it's separate from society
is going to be mainstream everywhere
five years down the road.
And so that's,
that's a big.
Is the vanguard academically?
No,
there no doubt.
Do you think what's happening now in
terms of a media and politics?
You could,
uh,
could say you could preemptively if
diagnosed that from what's happening
five,
10 years years I
think.
I think.
I think that in some sense I was
preemptively diagnosing it because I've
been watching the politically correct
postmodern types for quite a long time.
And one of the C,
one of the things I noticed about five
years ago,
six years ago,
there were two things that I noticed
that I really didn't like.
The first is that because I'm a
personality psychologist,
as a researcher,
not as a clinician,
but as a researcher,
I know the literature on gender
differences in personality because it's
part of my field and I could tell that I
was starting to have some reluctance to
deliver the lecture on gender
differences and now I didn't stop,
but I felt,
I felt that I was treading on thin ice
by delivering those lectures and I
thought,
oh,
that's not good because I'm like a
comedian.
I'm pretty much willing to say anything
that I think is true and,
and you know,
regardless of the consequences in some
sense,
because I'd rather take the consequences
of what's true.
And I thought this isn't good because if
someone like me who's,
you know,
rather uncontrollably mouthy let's say,
is starting to have second thoughts
about teaching what's a very serious
topic and,
and something about which there's a very
well developed science.
Then how much are other people starting
to censor?
And at the same time,
my students,
many of whom were female,
were telling me that they were really
hesitant to talk about gender
differences in any of the courses they
were running.
And I thought,
oh,
this is not good,
this is seriously not good.
And so,
and it's certainly the case that,
that my colleagues censor themselves
increasingly on campus with regards to
the topics they're willing to discuss.
And it's subtle,
you know,
because imagine in a given lecture I
could discuss any of 10 things and three
of them are taboo.
Well,
I just won't discuss those.
And that's that.
That's kind of invisible censorship.
It's not like I'll get up and say,
look,
I could have talked to you about gender
differences in personality,
but I won't because I'm afraid I'll just
pick another topic because there's lots
of topics to choose from.
And that means there's going to be a
bunch of topics that are really
important because actually the issue of
sex differences in personality happens
to be really important that people just
won't talk about.
And the other thing that's so annoying
about this is that,
especially with regards to sex
differences in personality,
well,
let's say,
let's say that you're firmly on the side
of women.
Just for the sake of argument.
Well,
do you admit to or deny the existence of
sex differences in personality?
What's better for women?
Well,
you know,
the radical leftist basically say,
oh,
well those,
if you talk about sex differences,
then you're part of the oppressive
patriarchy and you're attributing to
women a different kinds of temperament
in the attempt to continue the
suppression.
But I could just as easily say,
it's like,
well,
wait a second,
like if you want to,
if you want to,
uh,
give the individual the greatest degree
of freedom,
you say,
look,
you,
you're different from another person.
You're different on the basis of a
variety of your characteristics.
Sex being one of them that's going to
have some effect on what sort of choices
you want to make in your life.
It's like go ahead and make whatever
choices you want as far as their direct
expression of your being.
And so if you deny the existence of
these sex differences,
which no one knows,
serious commentator in the psychological
literature,
in the personality domain,
and those are the people that know about
this thing,
nobody debates whether or not sex
differences in personality exist or that
they have a biological component.
No.
And what's also interesting about that
is that none of those people are
conservatives.
There are no conservative psychological
researchers to speak up there in a tiny
minority.
So the people that have done the
research indicating that there are
differences between the sexes and
personality and that those differences
have a biological,
in part a biological component.
Those are liberal and left leaning.
People who've drawn those conclusions
despite their,
you know,
despite what their ideological
presuppositions might have suggested to
them to begin with.
So,
well,
so you know,
it's,
I don't know what to say about that
except that it's all appalling.
I suppose the fear must be that
difference will ultimately be used for
leverage for status.
And that's a reasonable fear,
you know,
because because anything can be
manipulated,
but,
but claims of identity can have identity
of claims that,
that people are identical in some way
can also be used for the same reason.
You know,
if I insist that everyone is exactly the
same on all dimensions,
there's just as much of a totalitarian
threat lurking in there as there is the
threat lurking,
that we'll use differences as an excuse.
And we're also not having a serious
discussion about this.
It's like,
yeah,
there are men are overrepresented at the
top of the economic apex.
That's true.
It's a small minority of men by the way.
It's certainly not men in general,
but there are radically underrepresented
at the Bard overrepresented at the
bottom.
And believe me,
man,
like nobody cares about men who are
failures.
They are like off the bloody radar.
So,
and,
and there's no sympathy for men who are
failures.
So men stack up at the top and the
bottom and,
and,
and we don't have a discussion about
that and we don't have a discussion
about the fact that women are radically
underrepresented in dangerous jobs.
Although they are or in or in or in in
trades that require like brutal physical
labor,
women are radically underrepresented or
in or in jobs outside.
Women are radically underrepresented,
so the complaint is always,
well if you look at the top one percent,
it's there are more men than there
should be,
you know,
by pure sex division.
It's like,
well yeah,
but if you look at the bottom,
the reverse is true.
So if we're gonna have the discussion
which are,
and I don't really necessarily think we
should have that discussion,
but if we're going to have the
discussion then we should look across
the entire economic spectrum.
I wonder how much of this debate is
being governed by unconscious forces.
I wonder how much of what we're
experiencing is a manifestation of a va
on a well,
we're cartography has not yet been a lot
of it.
What are you thinking about?
Any particular part of it?
What I feel like is that the reason that
I say imagine that you are arguments
that are based on research are so
successful is because people are
expressing feelings as opposed to cogent
and researched arguments.
It feels like there is a powerful,
dominant patriarchy and no one can deny.
I mean that there is power there such a
thing as power and there are people that
benefit from structures being as they
are horse of class.
The point of those structures being the,
they are.
One of the things I've observed is that
whenever change is discussed,
my tendency has always been to be
sympathetic towards movements that are
about change or empowerment of what
might be termed disadvantaged groups.
Um,
the change is that when you are curious
about the resistance of change or the
difficulties that you face when trying
to bring about change,
look at who would be negatively
impacted,
where that changed to be bought about.
Usually that means that there's some
people for conservatism make sense to a
particular group of people.
One thing that I felt when I'm reading a
book,
whereas the,
you know,
like I,
I,
because I think you're coming from a
perspective of psychoanalysis and it
rings very.
The language rings true and the analysis
rings true.
That what I,
where I feel.
One question I was keen to bring to you
is when you talked about skateboarders
in the,
or I think it's the last but one chapter
and that spirit of uh,
uh,
a young people,
yeah,
courage and a willingness to try
dangerous things and push forward and I
wonder how that sits with the idea of a,
an earlier passage in the book where you
talk about,
uh,
the gratitude that we should feel for,
you know,
having time to read a book and the
ability to read a book and sort of
respect for the establishment and
systems that have been set up from which
we all benefit.
Because when I,
you know,
I,
I couldn't find it difficult to dispute
your opinion about sort of churlish what
would have been in the lexicon of the
day social,
social justice warriors and that kind of
somewhat rootless unresearched.
Right.
You know,
I,
I identify what you're saying.
There are people that can't keep their
bedrooms tidy will be careful before you
let them organize an economic system.
But like,
but,
but similarly like,
you know,
where is change going to come from?
Who are,
who is going to challenge them?
Huge
tyranny is it?
Those are the sorts of twin forces that
we have to contend with across the
political spectrum,
so I could run through something quickly
to put the things that you just that you
just brought up in,
in,
in perspective.
Let's say.
Okay,
so the first thing is,
is that hierarchies.
If you're going to value some things
more than others,
then hierarchies are inevitable and you
have to value some things more than
others or you don't have anything.
You all strength for something.
Well,
what competence or shirt,
whatever,
whatever it happens to be.
The ability to play the flute,
right?
It doesn't matter why on my list.
Well,
what?
What you know,
obviously if you value music,
then you're going to value some
musicians more than others because some
are better.
So it's and so you have to value things
in order to move forward in life and you
have to value things in order to have
something valuable to produce.
But if you play out the value and the
social landscape,
you're going to produce a hierarchy.
And the problem with producing a
hierarchy is that a small number of
people are going to be successful than
the majority and a very large number of
people aren't going to be successful at
all at at that particular thing.
It's inevitable.
So okay,
now.
So.
So you would say,
well we have to put up with that because
we need to pursue things of value.
Okay,
fine.
So that's the right wing perspective is
that the hierarchy's are justifiable,
unnecessary.
Now the left wing perspective is,
yeah,
but wait a minute.
The problem with hierarchies is that
people stock up at the bottom and that
they tilt towards tyranny across time.
And that's also true.
And so you need that dialectic in
society between the right wing that
says,
you know,
we need the hierarchies and they're
useful and you should be grateful for
them and they structure you and give you
form and provide value.
And the left that says,
yeah,
but they exclude people and people stock
up at the bottom and that's dangerous to
the hierarchy itself.
And it,
it means that people might not have
opportunity.
And you have to say yes to that.
The problem comes,
and this is the situation we're in right
now where the radical leftists,
and this is mostly a problem that really
permeates the universities.
The radical left is say,
yeah,
but all hierarchies are just tyrannical
power.
It's like,
oh no,
they're not.
Hierarchies are based on competence in a
functioning society and mostly our
society functions,
so you need it.
You can't go that far.
Now that doesn't mean that the
hierarchy's don't tilt towards self
interest and tyranny across time,
but that's a bad thing.
It's even a bad thing from the
conservative perspective so well,
so there's room for the left.
There's room for the left because the
poor will always be with us.
That's the reason that there's room for
the left and that the dispossessed need
a voice not least because there are
talented people among the dispossessed
and if they're stuck at zero,
everyone suffers because we don't have
access to their talents.
It's bad use of resources,
but on the right it's like,
no,
we need the damn value hierarchies and
we need to be grateful for our
traditions and our structures because
they,
they stop us from degenerating into
chaos.
Oh,
so across the society,
numerous hierarchies emerge and at some
point decisions are being made about
which thing you know,
easy being a brilliant flutist or
brilliant at tennis or brilliant owning
land or controlling energy resources or
dominate in financial systems which are
the hierarchies that are most important
and also the what because it's the way
that resources are designated and
challenging.
Those hierarchies seems to become,
well almost impossible.
I'm,
when I was leaving the hospital,
that brilliant hospital,
they've been taken care of my mother
recently,
the window at the level of crisis and
trauma and tragedy there.
Excellent.
They've got the sort of best doctors
that guy might in griffith that operated
on her bow.
He's like a fantastic surgeon.
He is in fact him that trump was quoting
when he talks about European hospitals
with blood spatter flows from knife
crime.
It was a sort of a mangling of a quote
that this might in griffith a given and
then sort of like,
I step outside,
like I'm driving along along white
chapel road and there are um,
electronic advertising boards and the,
uh,
you know,
that require energy to tell me to eat,
sort of Mcdonald's or kit kats or
whatever,
and there's so much poverty on that
street.
There always has been in that part of
Eastland and terrible poverty and I feel
moments.
There are moments when I helicopter out
to the macro perspective that no
individual can long hold or wait,
that can't be long born.
But in that moment I think,
why is this hospital struggling for
resources when we can afford to run
electronic adverts for Mcdonald's?
Who gets to decide how collectively and
individually do we determine where
resources and where power both in terms
of energy but also in terms of human
power and up.
How were these decisions made?
And as you say,
among the dispossessed,
there is,
there are great resources,
great talent.
One would imagine if the research were
possible to the exact same degree.
Is there is power and talent and among
the possessed,
because it's normally an accident of
birth that decrease in reading about
your early life in Canada in a blue
collar community and this sort of the
mental health issues and the anger and
agitation that grows there.
So much of that is about resources.
The dispossession of the native people
of that area,
the mental health issues.
If your friend Chris like that.
For me,
we are rising through these hierarchies.
We that have experiences of both side of
that line.
Well,
we are now challenging this evolutionary
force.
We are now in a position to talk about
these hierarchies,
how they're ordered and how they're
organized and whether there is room for
negotiation.
Well,
it's up to us to do that because there's
a risk in conservatism is saying,
well this is how the cards have fallen.
Of course there is.
That is the risk and conservatism,
so how do we use confront that?
While the risk is the,
the,
the hierarchies ossified and turn to
stone,
and then there's no mobility and and the
idea that that things can turn to stone
and they become tyrannical is an
extraordinarily old idea.
For example,
in,
in the story of Exodus,
the story of Moses,
so the Egyptian,
the Egyptians are portrayed in that
story as tyrannical conservatives
essentially.
Right?
And they're masters of stone and Moses
is a master of water and water is the
thing that dissolves.
And so that drama's being played out in
these stories that are thousands of
years old and in the Egyptian story,
the ancient Egyptian story of Osiris and
Horus ocirus is the old king who becomes
too rigid.
And what happens to him is that he's,
he's dismembered by evil.
That's the consequence.
And so even the Egyptians long ago knew
that the danger of hierarchies as they
become static and corrupt and tyrannical
and part of what we do in our ongoing
political dialogue and,
and,
and when it's genuine dialogue is to
say,
well look,
are these,
do these systems have it?
We need them.
They're there not avoidable,
but do they,
are they functioning properly?
Are they loose enough so that people can
move?
Are they.
Are they serving the broader good or
have they degenerated into something
that's too tyrannical now you know you.
You kind of pointed to both of those in
the way you formulated that question
because you said,
look,
well,
my mum was in the hospital and she
needed care and so and I found a surgeon
who was an excellent surgeon and so.
So what you did there basically was take
a bow to the you bowed before the
functional hierarchy of the hospital and
said,
look,
the greatest surgeon actually rose to
the top and thank God for that because
otherwise my mother would be dead.
It's like,
yes,
that's our competency hierarchy and it
could be contaminated by tyranny.
In which case it would be the brother of
some powerful person who ended up with
the surgical position.
Right?
And then everyone dies and that does
happen in many,
many cultures where nepotism or
connections define your position on
every axis,
but then you said,
well,
but I went out of the hospital and I was
driving down the road and I saw what
appeared to be a misallocation of
resources and what we have to do about
that is have have a discussion about it
constantly.
It's like,
are we allocating resources to the
appropriate place?
Now the,
the other lurking problem there is to
what degree do we decide about the
allocation of resources by voluntary
effort,
by,
by planning,
and to what degree do we let the market
take care of it.
And that's also something that
continually requires negotiation.
That
market mate,
we don't trust that.
Well,
that's the.
That's the question is people talk about
it like it's a neutral thing,
but it's just a conglomeration of
interest of the powerful.
Well,
it's,
it's a bunch of things.
I mean it's that it can be that,
but it can also be the way that we
collectively value things.
Like,
let me give you an example,
our collective values,
and I'll just quickly say I heard this
thing,
and in Sweden they a contract regulate
and control access to alcohol at a state
level,
like off licenses or liquor stores.
They're sort of socially run and like,
and they're not allowed to be advertised
in Sweden,
Sweden,
I guess he's one of those havens of what
you might go.
I don't know what your views are.
Sweden by see a lot of stories about
Sweden.
They seem a bit like a,
Hey,
we swayed and comes across as this.
I guess I sort of this sort of
postmodern democracy almost in some
respects.
Anyhow.
Uh,
like I,
I thought it was curious that they
control alcohol in that manner and I am
envisaged the sort of breweries and
liquor distributors would say,
Hey,
that's not free market.
You're controlling access to people's
access to alcohol as if somehow the free
market was neutral,
but there is no neutral.
If the market is what has the power of
people's desires will be overly
stimulated.
People in people like if people are have
McDonald's,
advertise that they're more alcohol,
advertise that them people bloody
McDonald's
and alcohol.
There has to be some more realizing
force.
There has to be something that's not
economically lead.
That's not the manifestation of greed
that's in the conversation.
Someone in a secular society where there
is no reasonable or trusted voice of God
have to be able to say don't drink too
much alcohol or Mcdonald's because
people will.
Okay,
so.
So see,
I think.
I think the most effective solution to
that problem is to have the economic
system run,
let's say by distributed individuals who
are themselves aiming at a higher good.
So I think the way that you,
the most effective way of regulating the
market so to speak,
is to improve the moral character of the
people who make up the market rather
than directly regulating the market and
not that the market doesn't necessarily
need some regulation because you might
say,
well how about we don't devote alcohol
advertising to children under 10?
Most people would agree that that's a
reasonable perspective.
And so that is limitation on market
forces and there are places that you can
find that,
um,
that,
that limitation being accepted by almost
anyone,
but,
but part of what you're pointing to is
that if the only thing that's governing
the market is concerned for pure market
success,
than the market can produce all sorts of
excesses.
But I think what you want,
you want,
what you want is to help orient people
towards a transcendent good.
That's a,
Oh,
that's over and above market interest.
So you might say,
well,
what interests should you serve as
you're trying to be successful as a
comedian in while you're trying to make
a living as a comedian say you might
want to make sure that you're conducting
yourself appropriately in the
marketplace.
You're concerned about yourself,
but also your future selves because you
have to take.
And that's partly why addiction is such
a catastrophe,
right?
Because it's great in the short term,
but it's not so good in the medium to
long run.
So you have to take care of yourself
and,
and your,
your iterations through the future.
You have to take care of yourself in a
way that you're taking care of your
family.
You have to take care of yourself and
your family in a way that you're
benefiting the community and that should
be foremost in your mind.
So then when you start to make economic
decisions,
even in your business,
you're not saying,
well,
I'm going to do whatever I can to make
as much money as I can.
You're going to say I'm going to do
whatever I can to make as much money as
I can while also making sure that I'm
taking care of myself and my future self
and my family and my community and being
like greg grateful for all of that and
serving it properly.
And then I think the market can work
more effectively but still might require
some,
some discussion around the edges because
you know,
nothing is simple.
So the,
the reason that I'm concentrating on the
individual and individual development is
because I think that's the best way to
do that regulation.
I think that's important.
I think it's non negotiable.
I think it's necessary,
but I also believe that if you have a
society that's predicated on the some of
the worst aspects of human
behavior and it lost the desire,
fear,
if last fear and desire are so high in
the mix,
if you're continually being prompted
towards own in Islam and consuming,
I think it's the individual improvement
will be insufficient.
I I feel that your success is,
but I don't know it was based on,
but I feel like to a degree you've
contacted people and oh yeah,
I can improve my own life.
I can have a bit of personal authority
and autonomy and I think that's hugely
positive,
but if every time you step out of your
house every.
If every time you interface with society
or pick up your phone or look at a
screen,
the aspect of yourself that's being
nurtured,
that's being invited to participate on
the lower aspects of your nature because
those are the most successful routes to
a person's decision making impulses and
I think that it's difficult to exceed.
I think it's difficult for these
individual projects to to succeed.
I think that your know certain people
will have that,
that message will take hold,
but others it won't,
so on to some degree we.
I feel like I am a big fan of
regulation.
I understand your irritation about
what's being like this sort of a post
modern deconstruction analyst argument
of that destroy God that has destroyed
all categories.
Man,
woman,
none of it's real.
I believe in essence,
the humors,
the deities,
the gods.
I feel these things are present,
but I feel that we're already being
subject.
We're kind of invisible tyranny,
that it's already happening and I don't
think it's happening as a result of some
critical theory postmarks.
It's like,
I feel like that that's not where power
is,
that it feels like it's sort of.
It doesn't feel like it's just fucking
powerful.
Was Glaxo Klein or like,
no,
it's not as powerful as a Halliburton or
like,
you know,
these.
That's what I'm interested is power,
real power and how power is functioning
and how power is negatively impacting
ordinary people.
Well,
I think it's perfectly reasonable to
point out that there might be multiple
ways that people experience tyrannical
oppression now because every hierarchy
is going to tilt towards tyrannical form
in its own particular way,
and so I've been concerned about what's
happening in the university on the
radical left and your concern,
the concern that you just brought up is
something like a overwhelming large
scale corporate dominance and I think
that's also a reasonable set of
concerns.
You know,
it might not be for the best,
for example,
that all of our communication is
filtered through google.
That might be a bit too much.
The question is,
the question always is what we can do
about it,
and I think the answer,
the answer is an answer to that.
Actually.
The answer is we can lead people's
ability to communicate untrammeled and
so that's why I'm an advocate of free
speech.
We can leave people's ability to
communicate untrammeled so that we can
have intelligent discussions about those
as they emerge
and hopefully work towards solutions
because we can't just generate a
structure rules that says,
well,
here's the 10 rules that are going to
deal without complex situation because
things change too rapidly for that.
And the reason that freedom of speech as
far as I'm concerned is the paramount
freedom,
the paramount,
right.
Also the paramount moral obligation is
because it's through the,
it's through our ability to exchange,
to,
um,
to exchange honest opinions that we
participate in the process that enables
us to keep tyranny of the sort that you
described and the sort that I described
at bay.
And so part of the reason that I've
taken the tack I have politically is
because while my government had the gall
to implement compelled speech
legislation without noticing what it was
that they were interfering with,
because you might say,
well,
well that's,
that's pretty much the end of it.
How do you keep tyranny at bay?
Free?
The x?
The proper exchange of ideas between
free individuals keeps tyranny at bay.
That's the best we've got.
It doesn't work perfectly and it's also
I think a gift that England and in in
large part has given to the rest of the
world to formalize and codify that to
put it into a body of law to erect
governmental structures that are really
predicated on that idea.
It's a remarkable achievement and it's
something we should be profoundly
grateful for.
Thank you.
I want to talk to you about the taking
that accepting praise on the behalf of
England.
There as an English person accept that
there are two dragons.
Then there is the inner and the at least
until we've reached some non-dualistic
utopia where everything is one.
There is the inner dragon of our own
desires and fears,
but I suppose like when we're talking
about management of resources,
is that a phrase that we came up
earlier?
Let the where where does the attention
need to go and it's difficult like you
know me,
I suppose there's something about my
background that has led me to identify
as the Dragon.
Oh,
is consumerism is turning people into
consumers because obviously as an addict
that's what I am,
a consumer and a truck and Cima and it
seems that you,
with your background in academia are
the,
a neo Marxist post because like when I
sort of like think about aspects of
socialism,
egg,
you know,
people are working to artist only work
four hours a day.
They should be time for fishing in the
afternoon,
which I think is in Das capital.
He talks about fishing in the afternoon.
Yeah.
For me that seems like a very beautiful
and fair and just idea.
Also I don't see them like,
yes,
I can imagine that they're irritating on
a campus.
Particularly for somebody who's research
such a law.
I don't see them as powerful.
That's my,
that's part of my intrigue.
I suppose it's comparable to when I was
talking to Sam Harris,
another post who I admired,
but who am I going?
Oh yeah,
but I don't like,
you know,
like when I'm talking to Sam Harris
about Islam,
but when like where's,
how
is Islam and gonna be like,
I feel like even if he's aware of Saudi
Arabia and Wahhabism like Saudi Arabia
as an economic entity then on Islamic
entity in terms of race,
go do some Islam.
It's like they go do some business.
No,
and so I suppose here,
well my,
when I'm concerned mostly I'm concerned
mostly with the emphasis on,
on the collective identity rather than
the individual identity.
Like the process that you just
described,
I would say,
and this is the answer to the question
that you posed at the beginning of our
conversation is is there something
universal about the process that you
laid out?
And I think there is and I think it's at
the core of individual development and I
think it's the most powerful of forces
and so I think that the individual
should be regarded as the proper locus
of evaluation.
And the problem I have with the
postmodern new Marxists types,
apart from the fact that their analysis
tends to lead to a kind of nihilism,
is that because they're making the group
the paramount level of analysis,
this sort of thing gets ignored.
And I what I'm trying to do in my work,
we have a program called the self
authoring program that kind of steps
people through these 12 steps that you
just described.
The first thing that people do is write
about their past all the emotional
experiences.
The second thing they do is take an
inventory of their personality,
faults and virtues so that they can
rectify the faults and capitalize on the
virtues.
And the third thing they do is chart a
course for the future that takes them
into account and others.
And so,
and I see it as a reflection of this
universal process that you just
described it.
I think it's the most powerful form of
transformation,
but more importantly,
I also think it's the one that risks
doing the least harm.
Like it hasn't hurt anybody that you've
put yourself together.
It's just good.
Writing is good for you.
It's good for the people that know you,
there's nothing about it and it's.
It's the right level of humility because
you took what you knew to be wrong in
your experience.
You took personal responsibility for it.
You made changes for yourself.
You didn't go around pointing the finger
at what was wrong with the external
world and trying to fix it.
Now look,
it could easily be that once you have
your act together or maybe even before
you should be doing some things to
adjust political systems or sociological
systems,
but the problem with that is what makes
you think you can trust yourself?
You know,
and it's like,
well,
I'm compassionate.
Like maybe maybe you're also envious of
the successful and the probability of
that is pretty damn high by the way,
and so you better know before you
express that compassion,
especially in the political domain,
whether or not that is contaminated by
things about yourself that you haven't
contended with.
Do you think a declaration or along
those lines,
I'll specifically that in the political
field would be refreshing?
Look,
I'll tell you one of the.
This is a very funny thing,
so the ancient,
the emperor of Ancient Mesopotamia,
so this is some of the earliest
political we have.
By the way.
Here's what they used to do to the
emperor.
Every new year's Day,
they would take them outside the walls
of the city,
so he was responsible for everything
within the walls.
Outside was chaos on the unknown.
They'd take them outside the city.
They'd strip him of all his emperor
garb,
so he's no longer emperor.
They'd make them Neil,
they'd humiliate him.
I think the,
if I remember correctly,
the priest would hit them with a glove
and say,
okay,
in the last year,
how name all the ways that you didn't
embody Marduk Marduk was the god of the
Mesopotamians.
Marduk was the thing that took on the
great dragon of chaos,
and so it was the.
It was the responsibility of the emperor
is to kneel down and say,
here's all the ways that I haven't been
acting out my proper self,
and it brought the kingdom into
disarray,
and then he will be forgiven.
They would act out the reconstruction of
the cosmos.
That was the New Year's celebration and
then he'd go in and try to be a good
king.
I like so.
Yeah.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Absolutely.
It's like the confession of the emperor
is this the way I haven't been good at
anything
comparable.
A the powerful held up to that kind of
evaluation in.
We don't have rituals for that.
Well,
I suppose we don't acknowledge the
emergence of order from chaos.
We don't have a a merge or acknowledge
divine principles,
so the powerful light,
and I think this is possibly because of
assumed meritocracy,
but people that are in positions of
power,
they're there for a reason.
You don't need to start stripping him
naked and take them outside the city and
Santa.
How often did you rank in that Oval
Office everyday get out.
Yeah,
well,
I think there might be something to that
and that's the danger of pride that goes
along with ascension and a hierarchy.
Well,
because I'm here in this position,
I must deserve it.
It's like,
yeah,
but there should still be something that
you're bowing down to and that might be
the abstract idea of sovereign authority
itself.
If you think about it only
psychologically,
that's a figure that essentially has a,
a touch of divinity about it because
it's
be on a key right now.
Harm.
So that's the Queen,
the anointed and appointed monique,
she represents so.
But I suppose in a post secular nation
she becomes the emblem of Britain,
Robin,
the emblem of God on right.
Well,
I think,
I think it actually functions to some
degree in the same way as well.
I do think so because the queen
your queen in particular our queen as
well because I'm Canadian.
Aiden,
you know,
I mean,
I think Elizabeth has been a,
uh,
an embodiment of moral virtue.
I mean,
she's done a remarkable job over the
last,
what is it,
75 years now she's held herself to an
incredibly high moral standard and I
think she does sit in the background as
emblematic of what
sovereign authority might look like.
Of course you're a postmodernist and
this is an area where,
because I'm English and I can't get away
from the love of the Queen,
but I would also say that she is an
emblem of authority and of power and
wealth and land owners shit,
and there is that,
there is an order that will be respected
and can't be challenged every so often
in this country,
sort of toys with the idea of
republicanism that always
grateful when there's a wedding,
right.
There is this week so that no one has to
think,
is this right?
Are we paying for these bizarre
spectacle?
Yeah.
Well,
but it.
But it is useful to think about it in a
symbolic sense.
I mean,
one of the things that constantly
threatens the United States,
I think there should be four branches of
government,
legislative,
judicial,
executive,
and symbolic.
Because the problem in the United States
is the president keeps tilting towards
king,
you know,
the Americans like the idea of the first
family and the first lady.
And it's like,
yeah,
no,
and,
and kind of tilts towards a dynasty.
And you've seen that happen with the
bushes and the Clintons and it's not,
it's not a good thing,
and it might be nice to have someone
take the symbolic load off the president
and just act that out.
And your queen does that very nicely
because all of the pomp and circumstance
of the state and all the drama and
ritual of the sovereign can be played
out in that sort of dramatic space.
And your legislature and executive
branches can go off and do.
The administration is interesting that
the,
uh,
the dentist steeze exert themselves in a
sense.
It's a demonstration of your argument
that there are certain hierarchy systems
that find their way into fruition
regardless of regulation.
But then I suppose there's rational
reasons they would have the resources,
the experiences that can make the
connections.
It's easier for them.
But that's also the,
that's a danger to a republic is the
fact that.
And it's part of the potential
corruption of the state is that while
it's easier for the children of those
who have authority to have power and you
don't want people attaining the pinnacle
of achievement because of power,
he wants to attending the pinnacle of
achievement because of competence.
Yeah.
And those things always struggle.
They all.
And,
and it,
it,
it takes a society that's very awake to
stop the hierarchies from degenerating
into hierarchies of power because the
generation is the tendency chirp.
While it's easy,
it's easy.
Wba Pam.
Yeah.
Fearsome and terrifying.
Uh,
you know,
the full cannot pallium well,
and people have recognized that it's the
proclivity of hierarchies to,
towards tyranny,
for,
for really,
for thousands of years,
I've seen that as a fundamental danger
to proper adaptation.
We need hierarchies,
yes.
But they degenerate into tyranny and
they unfairly oppressed.
It's like,
yes,
we have to be on guard against that,
but that doesn't mean that we call all
hierarchies tyrannies because that's not
helpful.
Or we call all productive activity
service in the,
in the service to the oppressive
patriarchy because that's seriously not
how helpful and we don't dispense with
hierarchies because then people don't
have anything to do.
So.
Yes.
So I see.
I get the beam out your.
I say if the individual is tuned,
if the individual is I channel that I
like a prayer of Saint Francis,
I like.
It is a multiple.
The invites us to find the reverse of a
h,
a defective characteristic.
We all seen that we might be living out
to become a channel of some inherent
goodness.
Well,
the thing that's one of the things
that's interesting rolled out or two
things actually.
The first is the word sin means to miss
the target.
It's an archery term.
So that's quite.
That's a very interesting way of
thinking about it because it means that
there is a target,
there is a target.
That's the thing,
but the next thing is,
and this comes right out of that,
is it's very useful to become aware of
your faults because as soon as you pause
it a fault,
you pause it the opposite by merely
saying,
well,
that's a fault.
You're saying implicitly,
while there's something that's the
opposite of that,
so out of your recognition of faults
immediately some clarity of virtue
develops because you might say,
well,
this is a fault and I really know it.
It's like,
great.
You've got some bedrock there.
Whatever the opposite of that fault is,
you might not know what that is,
but whatever the opposite of that fault
is is a virtue,
and then you might say,
well,
I have 20 faults.
It's like great.
The opposite of the personality that has
all those 20 faults is the virtuous you,
whatever that might happen to be,
well,
great.
Then you've then you've conjured out of
the devil.
I'm a redeemer.
It's something like that.
I like that,
and then I'm down to play both in terms
of cosmology and fleeting morality.
There is chaos,
there is vastness,
but there are also patterns.
There are patterns that emerge and
whether you call that pattern mail or
love or beauty,
there are various patterns and I feel
that there is something to get in
alignment with.
There is a tune,
there is harmony,
there is melody,
there is grace would not.
And all you're using their musical
musical.
Um,
what would you call analogies,
presentations.
That's what music expresses is to have
all of that in harmony,
live music because of that,
you know,
in those patterns,
because music,
you think about music,
it is the harmonious interaction of
patterns and you just described all
those positive,
uh,
what would you call them?
Spirits.
That's a good way of thinking about it
as patterns.
While they are patterns.
Then you might think that there's a
pattern that's composed of all of those
patterns.
Well,
that's what you're after.
You're after the pattern that's composed
of all those patterns.
Yes,
absolutely.
And you want to put yourself in harmony
with that.
And that is a real thing.
That's a real thing.
You can feel that.
So it's what keeps you alive essentially
when you're trying to become conscious.
He,
yes,
yes.
There is something important happening.
I feel like what we were saying before
about the acknowledgement of difference
need an infor inferiority.
That is something that is definitely not
what we should be actually.
Well,
this is part of what the radical leftist
keeps saying is what we should celebrate
diversity.
It's like,
yes,
but what that means first is the
admission that people actually differ.
You don't have diversity.
It's like,
I'm glad there are conservatives.
I'm glad there are leftists.
The conservatives run things.
The leftists invent them.
It's like good and they're really
different.
Those people like you know,
if you have a group that's all
conservatives and they're going down the
right path,
they're going to go down that path
really fast,
but if they're going down the wrong
path,
they're not going to be able to think
laterally and figuring out how to get
out of it.
If you have a group of of left leaning
creative types,
it's like they're going to come up with
100 ideas,
but the probability that they'll
organize in a stable hierarchy and
implement those effectively is zero.
They're going to have to call over the
conservatives.
It's like,
look guys,
we finally got a good idea.
You can have one idea because you're
conservatives run with it and then they
can all run with it and so it's really
good that we have people who are like
that on both sides of the distribution
because otherwise the,
the creative types and sit around and
come up with new ideas until they starve
to death in squalor and the are.
Well.
Exactly.
And the Conservatives would just ossify
and,
and you know,
run down a road that got narrower and
narrower and narrower and they'd all end
up stuck between two cliffs and that'd
be the end of it for both of them.
Thesis,
antithesis,
synthesis.
We require synthesis.
This is how does the interplay of
opposites.
Actual opposites.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They Yin-yang that over the s there
needs to be necessarily collusion
between distinction,
but for that to happen,
that needs to be acknowledgement and
recognition of difference.
But in a,
trying to achieve a quality with the
annihilation of category is no
successful.
That's exactly right.
That's not a successful route.
Thank you doctor.
Professor Jordan,
psn.
We have good chats.
Steinway.
That was great.
Yeah,
that was really good.
Hmm.
Absolutely.
Thanks for inviting me back.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you,
Tammy.
Thank you.